this  is breaking news on 8 news now  and we will get to those stories in a  moment but first look at this  firefighters responding to a two-alarm  fire this is happening  not too far from the boulevard and okie  authorities say  at least one person could be inside  sorry our crews are still getting set up  here when these live images might be a  little jumpy  the building appears to be an old  wedding chapel  so we do have a crew on the way to the  scene and we'll bring you more  information as it becomes available  of course we'll keep an eye on it for  you this is again near las vegas  boulevard and okie street  so that surrounding area it's going to  be closed for a while again this is a  two alarm fire so if you can  please avoid the area if at all